well of course the moderna and pfizer
vaccines continue to be slowly
distributed
throughout the country but one of the
many obstacles
officials are running into is that many
african americans remain skeptical
of these new covid vaccines now i wanted
to understand the complexities
of this skepticism so i invited a good
friend of the show dion
cole to help explain this to me dion
welcome conan thanks for having me
brother i'm glad to have you here so
dion it's my understanding
that many black americans don't trust
the new covid 19 vaccines is that right
that's right conan and the reason is
very very simple
have you heard of history card yes i am
familiar with the concept of history
that's just it black people have
historically faced discrimination from
both the u.s government
and health care institutions yeah well
that's fair it still seems important
though that we get people vaccinated so
what can we do great question conan
that's why i am happy to announce an
up-and-coming alternative the black
scene
i'm sorry say that again what what's the
black scene
it's basically the same as the moderna
and fisa vaccine
but with a little more flavor to it
so you're saying there's going to be an
alternative covet vaccine that's just
for african-americans
that's right conan it's being developed
by fubu oh
wait a minute fubu how come i haven't
heard of this
well did you hear about lil nas x's new
children book
i did not exactly uh there are concerns
about the vaccine's ingredients do we
know what's in the black scene
oh yeah conan tons of good stuff cocoa
butter
tea tree oil ginger ale uh vicks vaporub
uh but most importantly absolutely no
white nonsense
oh no white nonsense okay well what if a
white person
were to take the black scene conan conan
conan
i'm disappointed in you what what did i
do ain't that just like a white man
trying to appropriate something that's
supposed to be
ours first will smith now this oh come
on
i just wanted to know what would happen
well honestly conan i don't think you'll
like it
it'll probably be too spicy for you oh
probably true well there is at least a
specific schedule then to
who gets the black scene first is there
is there an order to who gets it
definitely but the distribution schedule
is a little bit
different it goes frontline workers
grannies
aunties uh our brave men and women of
weed distribution the cast of blackish
and then everybody
else yeah well you've got it all worked
out then dion cole thanks so much for
explaining to me dion cole everybody